are you all ready to see your
fixer-upper
here's your exclusive first look at
season 4 a fixer-upper with makeover
moguls chip and Joanna Gaines yeah
what's your name again
Jay it's nice to meet you casting did a
heck of a job like we knew each other of
the husband-and-wife team from Waco
Texas it's definitely Jeb who loves
playing the goofball I list trees and
climb ability to have picture here but
and Cameron while visiting the games at
their 40-acre farm saw chips playful
side firsthand Oh what Joe I said I
thought it was gonna be a dead animal
it's just an egg it's a permit to farm
better days does that happen pretty much
all the time I always have to look over
my shoulder I'm like what is he about to
do I mean dad she thinks it's always
gonna be disgusting usually it's sweet
it's like a brilliant thing do you guys
think we need any more dogs yes we need
five more these parents are for kids
ballets family and business while
turning dumps into dream homes ready to
see your fixer-upper
yeah for me it's a dream come true
because at the end of the day what we're
passionate about is creating home for
families you just thought we'd be
successful but I mean did you think
you'd ever be anything never a TV show
and never on this national like platform
because beams look awesome
[Music]